hey guys welcome back to brand-new video
we're back on foreign again today is
January 31st the launch of season 9 I'm
so excited I cannot wait to play after
this video goes live but just real quick
my discord and Twitter will be in the
description if you want to join that
we've got a pretty active discord server
and on top of that I will most likely be
streaming after this video goes live so
keep on the channel and wait for that
because I want to be in the stream I'm
gonna have some first-time reactions to
season 9 I'm gonna show it off and play
with you guys and stuff like that so be
aware of it for that but regardless
let's get into today's video so first up
there really wasn't much to talk about
it was the release of season 9 so I'm
expecting the next couple weeks to be
pretty lackluster in terms of content
but first up they showed the February
roadmap and as I said nothing too crazy
basically the only thing that is worth
noting is that February 14th is the
second anniversary of for owner so
congrats the devs for that and a double
xp fest taking somewhere later in the
month
other than that it's been filled with
arcade quests event playlists challenges
and weekly content as usual so I don't
really expect to see too much crazy
content this month there is going to be
a seasonable event within this month but
I believe it's going to start happening
in March so definitely be aware for that
speaking of new arcade quests there is a
new arcade quest this week and they're
probably really isn't any different from
any other arcade quest but the reason I
talk about it is because there's new
outfits and an effect that you can get
the old effect the Crimson conquests the
one we all know about well since there's
a new season we get into effect I'll
show it on screen it is called the pink
plasma shock effect looks really [ __ ]
cool and there's a new battle outfit as
well which honestly pretty bunch pairs
up with the effect and looks really nice
as well I'm not a big fan of battle
outfits but I definitely copped this
100% kind of bummed that it's a little
bit of a reskin of a previous mythic I
believe it's a masker mythic I believe
it's a mythic outfit with just different
colors it's the Solaris one for the
Knights the I forgot what it is bill you
don't understand if you look through the
mythix it's a little it's basically the
same just different colors and I'm kind
of bummed out about that but it still
looks great I like the pink definitely
gonna be rocking that on top of that
there's a new event playlist called
harbor which matches you only in the new
harbor map on top of that there's also a
new event place to go with this and it
says to be the faction with the most
amount of executions and the harbour
event playlist and the winning faction
gets three
I was in steals so definitely hop on and
try to get that 3000 steal cos new
executions new character gotta get all
the steel you can there also of course
trying to improve matchmaking for
players so far they're testing a few
things in the coming weeks and it will
hopefully improve matchmaking nothing on
exactly what it is but it still sounds
very exciting I'm always down to improve
matchmaking and the next is the content
of the week and to start the season off
strong
we have masks outfits we have the
elegant sickness from the Knights
faction I believe the Valhalla acts the
near from the Vikings chuco's
metamorphosis from the samurai and
lonely Jew bow from the Wulin it looks
super dope I'm definitely gonna probably
grab the wool in one like the lion
outfit if I had to give like a top four
and you know from worst to best samurai
have to be the worst one kind of weird
if you're a male character Vikings one
is cool but not grave Knights have to be
second but I have to say that the
woollen get the best one personally I
like the lion outfit so if you want to
get any of those mask outfits for any of
the characters you definitely grab that
not entirely sure what the prices it's
probably similar to a normal mask outfit
so definitely be aware for that so try
to conserve your steel with a lot of
[ __ ] come in this season but I'm very
excited because really great start the
season already is starting with masks
outfits great stuff hey guys it's gonna
be the end of the vitae hopefully you
guys did enjoy it like I said not too
much come in this week in terms of
individual content besides the fact that
season diners are loosing the harbor
maps there the arcade stuff besides that
the stuff just from the dev stream like
I said not too much stuff in general
yeah let me know your thoughts on all of
it I'm very excited to go play arcade
quests look look out for an arcade video
actually I might be posting that either
before or after the stream I'll have to
see cuz I'm very excited to go play
arcade and get that effect we do it guys
like the V if you do enjoy subscribe
before new I covered the informational
side of foreigner that being balanced
changes here updates patch notes and
leaks so if you want to be kept up to
date with everything happening in
foreigner or not missed a single update
definitely subscribe to meet in the
channel and that guy's my two most
recent videos will be on screen if you
guys do want to check that out with that
guys hope every girl should I think
Bart's in the video and peace out
[Music]
you